[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what is good everybody how's it going
happy Thursday perchik here hope you
guys are having a good one it's another
animal crossing day I know you've been
doing a lot of animal crossing lately
but I mean it's animal crossing come on
yeah
big update launched today you know a
celebration of nature day which you know
I would assume was in tandem with Earth
Day and a lot of new stuff is here and
I'm really excited actually because I
mean I've been playing this game a lot
and you know I've gotten pretty far
along in terms of my island and you know
I got KK and all of that and just when
you think okay I've done everything say
like no there's so much more I love to
do so we're just gonna hang out today
I'm gonna show off some of this stuff so
I came up up date I did buy a few shrub
saplings I guess so I'm not gonna have
any full shrubs yet I don't know how
many days it takes vinegar or anything
like that but we'll find out and yeah
hello everyone out there Brandon what's
good welcome back hey Mike what's up
Gerald Werner and Beverly and koala hope
you guys are having a good one I'm
excited to play some Animal Crossing
soap when I first logged in this morning
hold up let me see some water here
when I first woke up this morning signed
in nature day they announced leave but
in the mail I got a few things so I got
this oh wait I moved it over here
this world map on the wall they're so
loud and turn them off real quick but
yeah that world map above the TV I got
that in the mail from Nintendo and then
apparently they reduce the interest rate
from the Nook Bank so this rug was there
you know their gift for doing that I got
two more of these rugs from friends who
didn't want them and I put it up here I
put it up here because whenever I buy
turnips I fill up this room with turnips
but I already sold my turnips too sweet
so there's nothing right now but I just
thought that it was cute and I wanted to
put all so you also get that rug and let
me know how everything everything sounds
I don't know how many hours I have in
this game actually I mean like I think
it's a lot by now let's see three
hundred and forty hours that's not that
many but yeah watch a cooking show yeah
yeah I've actually been watching Gordon
Ramsay has been doing some funny videos
like with celebrities and stuff teaching
them how to like make eggs and it's
pretty cool gotta make sure I've talked
to all my villages today you know I only
talked to a few so far I did thought
what do I have right now oh they set up
this bin we should say what so look guys
I can't leave so
cute so cute so I did buy some shrubs
already but they also have flowers that
are in like native to your island here
so I bought some lilies earlier I have a
lot of mums already s I didn't buy any
more months but I bought a bunch of
lilies and I bought five of each of the
shrubs so the shrubs are really pretty
they come in a bunch of different colors
I'm gonna try to plant some because I'm
really excited for shrub super-excited
I'm also excited about the art wing I
talked to blob is this morning and from
what I have heard so far is that once
you talk to blathers red will show up
the next day so Reds not on my island
today unfortunately but tomorrow
hopefully he'll be here
what's up doom Ouma Sergio how's it
going check the staple I've been getting
patterns from her now yay thank you I
finally got her to start giving me
patterns it took me a while because one
I didn't realize I had to talk to her
every day I just thought she just didn't
talk at all um I have a wand outfit on
so let me take it off so I can go
they're not turning up today they're not
they're not they're working out they're
chilling I just want to see what I have
in my store right now
scurrilous suspenders that sounds super
cute oh wait no I hit the wrong button
it's so hard hopping between like a
Nintendo console and anything else cuz
usually like the confirm and the back
buttons are swapped and I always mess up
always I know I was gonna plant shrubs
but you have to make time to like that
is so good so cute
oh I got some helmets here too
I'm good I don't need anything today I
mean it's also early my villagers may
turn up later also I'm looking for some
pitfall seeds or wanted if that's what
it's called right pitfall C's or
something like that I'm looking for some
I need some all right let's figure out
where do I want to put some shrubs
where's some shrubs be nice
much space do I have in my pockets I'm
gonna mount a space uh I think I'll wind
these sides here right like right here
this is alright a sprite I've like
gotten so used to how my my island is
that yeah I'm like what do I want
where do i little bit I know I
definitely want shrubs though yeah let's
give Remy some shrubs Oh Richie is not
feeling well today so he's not gonna be
here so I'm gonna try to keep an eye on
the chat for us what's good Luke I'm
happy we're playing Animal Crossing - I
love it so much
I'm obsessed in this game alright so
yeah I'll put some one both sides
whoops I didn't farm my rocks at City
either I need to remember to do that all
right
so let's see here I want to put a shrub
here and a shredder I guess I'll have to
put at least three over here I'll let
them know you uh you're wishing them
well mmm okay so I gave her or like
anything like a chili dog
so let's do let's do the yellow oh
they're so cute like they're not even
grown yet it's just a little stem but
I'm already like excited I am excited
for shrubs you guys very cool and
there's also besides red and leaf there
is more nook miles goals that you can
get bar view says is this game fun this
game is fun to me I love this game I've
spent over 340 hours apparently I just
checked um so yeah they you get Nick
miles plus rewards up here see limited
day limited time nature day activities
we just completed that one so give me
those hundred miles real quick I mean
thousand miles
I can't math what else is it
Oh shrubbery Hibou burry
[Music]
okay okay so certain shrubs will bloom
certain flowers depending on the season
I think leaf said the Azalea was in
season for me right now so that's gonna
be pretty two different types of flowers
Thank You Eduardo
what's up acid welcome to the stream
yeah I've spent so much time on my
island
Jessica was good welcome back girl how
are you we're playing AC again I'm just
checking out you know nature day stuff
oh wait I want to talk to Tom actually
because after you complete that first
natured a nook thing I think Tom gives
you something so let's say yes I did Tom
yay clap so like action oh so like you
jumped in action oh snap alright so
shrubs and hedges hmm I wonder what this
recipe consists of let's take a look
look at Isabel over there she got a
dusty old desk wait there causing all
that dust girl I should try to get
graham on my island I don't know if I
know who graham is instead of like a
villager or um let's see clumps of weeds
us
oh the cameras in the way so let me move
that real quick so I can actually read
what this is
boom yeah that's better I think oh that
actually covers my map I think so let's
put it up here everywhere ah all right
sorry yes don't mind me
all right cool I'm definitely gonna add
some hedges I have some I think I have
some clumps of weeds definitely have
branches and I have some stones
he's a yellow hamster out cute that's so
weird that they have like the pet
hamster and then actual hamster
villagers just like that like the owl
and then flowers okay
so we can also make some hedges which is
exciting I might be able to make a few
right now let's see or did I sell all of
my leaves I might have I might have to
hit up a mystery island possibly we'll
see actually Brandon I am working on
more a/c videos now - I just did the
custom design tips video that's up right
now with the help of David you guys have
seen me play destiny with David I'm sure
he's been on the stream a few times if
you did this scary movie once and he did
not enjoy it but he was still a trooper
alright so yeah I do still have some
clumps all right let's make some hedges
- some shrubs some hedges because the
hedges you know they're already in hedge
form right right whereas the shrubs I'm
have to wait until like at least the
next few days to uh at least see what
they look like
fully grown oh it's a fence
Oh got it
I don't know why I didn't realize that I
thought it was kind of like you know the
bamboo partition whatever it's called
partition
I have my own channel I do have a twitch
channel I stream from time to time
oh I realize that makes like ten stacks
right that means I just made thirty of
them didn't I get it oh my goodness
oops wasn't paying attention there
that's fine let's put this other stuff
away but yeah I am gonna be working on
some cool weekly stuff actually so yeah
stay tuned stay tuned for that I'm
excited about it I know we're also
trying to be careful not to do too much
and I'm crossing but me personally
there's never too much animal Krawczyk
alright I got to find a place for these
orange flowers also of some extra
recipes here yeah I have to always keep
my pockets a little organized they're
also sites that really drive me nuts so
we'll find a place for those roses
oh yeah that's another thing
good call-out loose-leaf buys your
clumps of weeds for a double with their
worth annex crannies so you can make 20
bucks per per so we'll definitely hit up
a mystery island so we can make some
money off some some clumps of weeds
we'll definitely just check out the rest
of GameSpot's channel for more Animal
Crossing stuff we have a ton of guides
like I mentioned earlier my custom tips
guide is up I mean that was mostly like
a group effort though so I don't want to
say it's all mine but it was super fun
and I'm excited to do some other stuff
which is gonna be like highlighting some
really cool community things so yeah
what's my opinion on time traveling I
think everyone should just play how they
want to play like in the beginning like
I'll admit I could not stand waiting
like for bridges and stuff so I would
like hop I know other people are like
totally against it and you know that's
fine too but I also know people who they
don't have all the time in the world to
play also so they have to you know do
what they can as well so you know I feel
like it is what it is everyone should
play how they want to play I am a
judgment-free person so okay I think I'm
gonna put this hedge fence here behind
the plaza I think that would be nice
I may also make two more science so yeah
let's dig these up exactly I'm just like
play how you want play how you want I
didn't a friend like make it sweet
recently like really angry about
time-traveling and I'm like if it's your
game play it my shovel and I feel like
without certain at least some people
time-traveling we wouldn't be able to
get all the cool stuff like some people
don't have access to like able sisters
and stuff like that too but there's all
these cool designs and these cool codes
you can download from out there right
now so you know and they've skipped
probably even more so than than most
people I am working on a second island
for something else coming up really
special and I definitely don't have time
to play two accounts at a normal pace so
I'm skipping a lot on that one so like I
feel like I'm kind of spoiling myself
now with stuff that I've seen so far
which is like a little bit of a bummer
because I did kind of like one of these
but I definitely need to get that island
done ASAP for what we're doing so so
yeah I feel like there's situations and
and personal preference and y'all should
just do what everyone
don't let your dreams be dreams all
right where are we at here
[Music]
what's up Gabriel welcome to this dream
I am currently experiencing the nature
day of been I bought some shrubs I
planted them I went and spoke to good
old Tom and he gave me a recipe for some
hedges so I'm remodeling this area back
here I'm gonna plant some hedges when I
really plant there a fence hedge fence
which is actually really cool because I
thought that were gonna be like the
bamboo partitions where I'd have to like
make a bunch and line them up but we
good all right so I'm going to put some
hedges here and see how it looks oh it
looks amazing
I love it oh my goodness I love it oh I
gotta move this log bench real quick I
wish you could get this angle all the
time so far from what I've seen you can
only get this angle when you're planting
a fence behind the building and it knows
that like you need to see you there at
planting obviously or using the island
designer app that looks awesome I might
I have think I have some of these
signposts left over if not all might
make some and put them on the other side
[Music]
this way I like it I like it I think I
might oh I was thinking about putting a
row of I'm here too I'm wondering if
that would be overkill my Creator code I
haven't made anything yet all of my
designs I've been using have been ones
I've been finding outlines everyone's so
good at it already I think the only
design I did was based off of another
design that I downloaded because I
wanted to change a few things but that's
about it
[Music]
how do you upgrade it how do you upgrade
your nook house like the shop or
resident services to kick the ground to
cover up a hole you press why that'll
also be something you use if you like
put a custom design on the ground and
you want to erase it you can use y oops
I didn't mean to do that I was just
mashing the button yeah my pop grandma's
you oh I didn't put my log bench down
either yeah which one you mean the next
granny this the store the shop or the
resident services hey sherry welcome
thanks for joining us
[Music]
there we go all right let's see where
else can we put some there's some weeds
over here now they feel so much more
valuable
[Music]
I know where else I could put some
hedges put some hedges here or should I
put some sure rubs I still have some
shrubs and I'm probably gonna buy some
more I want to put them all down it's
got to figure out the best piece where
is the best place for this a balloon oh
I should put Sun
I got a bra key oh I got a second
Braccio for my island
I might decorate this area it's just
this space is not that optimal but you
can see it when you fly over the island
which is why I put it here in the first
place
oh well if you're talking about your own
house then you have to go to resident
services and talk to Tom Nick and that's
and feel like ask him about your home or
something if you don't see that option
ask him what do I do and then he might
mention it but oops wrong button I don't
have a hard copy of this game I have
digital version I'm not really a fan of
getting hard copies anymore because you
know everything's digital now a flower
grew out here out of place it's my first
time noticing it
hmm I kind of want to put some hedges
around or some shrubs around here it's
just such a tight space I really need to
figure out what I want to do with this
dinosaur I want him here but I might
need to terraform the island a little
bit more i've already terraform it so
much but I could always make this little
creek like one smaller so let's see
thank you I have like all these outfits
I really like and now it's gotten to a
point where I can't decide which one I
want to wear all the time but I like my
character right now - we all ready all
right so I'm a terraform this a little
bit
oh no I'm covering this up
[Music]
[Music]
just don't want it to close this but it
will who it didn't okay
this one will
[Music]
hmm cam might dig up I'm running out of
space really fast okay boo I'm have to
dig up some trees let's go get some
fruit hello Shelly what's up but you
know the thing about digital games too
though is that you know if you don't
have the space for it like my Nintendo
I'm already out of space like my switch
my name is in the suite I'm already out
of space the bench I might put some
shrubs around the museum like where
these yellow flowers are need to go put
some stuff in storage free up since we
I'm gonna move those trees I'm gonna
tear from that little creek a little
more
what days do I stream we stream here on
gamespot every single weekday at 2 p.m.
Pacific time and we also have the UK
team doing some streams now which is
really exciting so you'll be able to
catch the UK streams on Tuesdays and
Thursdays our time it's really early I
think Pacific time is like 5 a.m. but
they are on GMT which I don't exactly
remember what that's it for but yeah
that's what online converters are for
that's what I use
[Music]
how do you upgrade your tent out your
resident services so after your nuts
cranny is open I think it takes like a
certain amount of days and then they'll
just announced that they're upgrading I
don't remember if there was a specific
requirement
I'm sure Callie knows yeah I'm trying to
think I don't really remember I'm gonna
eat this peach through my mask yeah I
think after knucks is up like eventually
resident services just like opens up too
so as long as you're still like inviting
villagers and stuff like that oh me
personally my bad I don't really have a
set schedule for my personal things
right now but it's mostly in the
evenings and on the weekends obviously
as I'm working but usually in the
weekends for sure
and then random evenings I likes history
usually oh I just picked up a full hour
on accident
now I keep missing the tree there we go
my bad Tasha did I mess up your your
fishing there my bad girl can you see
what my map looks like sure he sees my
lap I have a lot of like custom design
paths so those tests don't always show
up but you can see it where are my
regular paths are my rock Island looks
crazy but I love it
Brandon Bivens with it
how's it going oh and all my villagers I
love them so much I'm so attached to
them all that I don't want any of them
to move and I had a really cute villager
I think she was like a rare one - she
came to my I went to my campsite and I
wanted her to move in but I I couldn't
let go of anybody I can't I love the
ball so much I can't let them go but
yeah and when a camp site villager comes
to your Island apparently you can't
choose who leaves it's just a random so
I really can't risk it I really can cuz
then my favorite one might be gone the
Lawrence actually going really well it's
been a lot of fun yo Tasha just showed
up fell asleep she fell asleep where I
wanted to big they always do that they
always do that
hey I'm gonna need you to move I
remember I was decorating a faunas front
yard of one day and Teddy straight-up
came over and sat in the chair that I
was trying to switch out with a
different chair
oh come on Sasha not right now you know
oh man
[Music]
well hopefully she moves by the time I
pass that part this will really help my
Braccio drive no wrong one I'm not very
accurate with this crap know what I was
definitely not looking at we have it
ever won a videogame tournament contests
I mean I won a tournament before back in
the day in Halo 2 it wasn't nothing
crazy it was at my local Hollywood video
there was like 20 people it was fun
though I want a team tournament one time
and she fried herb I don't think that
counting because I definitely got
carried by my TV I don't know I have two
World Records and Tetris which isn't
really a tournament but it's some sort
of W in a sense
I think the biggest lie in Animal
Crossing is that any of these dresses or
jeans or pants that I'm wearing have
pockets
that's probably no I wish all the
pockets in my clothing or I could hold
this many things that would be great did
I win anything it was like I want a
poster I won like a gift card for the
store and like something else really
well a t-shirt that wasn't even halo
related like it was for a different game
yeah it was yep it was that game crazy
Brandon that was the site like
blockbuster had their own named one and
then Hollywood video had game crazy I
remember trying to apply a game crazy
and they dug lead in I hire me but it's
all good man Tasha is chilling right now
[Music]
um I have two one for fastest time trial
number one and then the other one was
like highest starting level highest
difficulty but that's one that you could
just max the points out of so I think I
ended up getting that one like tied with
another player how many yeah there we go
Sasha thank you girl
thank you I'm trying to Train to
terraform here really made me wait
didn't need a catching fish why don't
you let the villagers catch fish from
time dude I am I feel so bad for them
when they like are trying to catch fish
or bugs and they miss and they have like
a sad face I'm like alright I am gonna
put a shrub there I'm gonna need you
move it can I throw in the water we can
that would be so rude what was I looking
for oh yeah my hedges that would be so
fun actually
[Music]
maybe they're on the by the beach maybe
you should go upstairs that why are you
doing this to me tiger ooh these are
even pretty like if you don't connect
them all
come on side and I really just wanna put
this entry here
yeah thank you thank you very much I
said thank you for moving but more like
thank you for definitely getting pushed
out of the way all right I'm sorry I
took away here fishing spot there but
things to do
[Music]
even this so it's kind of bothering me
no it's yeah I'm just uh you know
redecorating I'm trying to change up
this area a little bit so that my shrubs
will look better around my Braccio over
here that's the goal but I keep ruining
your all-over fishing spots it's ok this
there's plenty of fishing spots over
here all right perfect
[Music]
I need to move this tree and need
another peach
[Music]
yeah those records were actually really
cool and my friend got it for me
recently actually but I have like two
little lines of text of my name in it
and the Guinness Book the gamers get the
Guinness Book of World Records 2013
gamers edition that could have been so
dangerous but money fell out I was like
oh no I don't want a wasp's nest to fall
out of that but my friend bought me the
book recently which is really really
sweet of them so I finally own it now I
didn't own it all these years and I got
it like at the end of last year it's
gonna throw these down later I'm
probably gonna end up moving them again
but it's fine or they could all just end
up looking really pretty and I leave
them all here okay gonna want to
cool we have to make sure the Braccio
has space and he's comfortable since
he's living on this island with us - I'm
not trying to get another t-rex I'm a
few parts I would still have a few parts
left I need to find and you find another
t-rex head and maybe like t-rex arms or
torso or check no I have his fur so it's
like arms maybe chest in and head unless
the last piece is just like the head and
the chest and the arms all connected
which would be really convenient but
yeah alright and I think I also want to
change this path to match the ground
over there so oh no my pockets are full
I can't pick them up Brad let's go plant
more flowers
when in doubt plant more flowers
actually I kind of want to put a shrub
here can I put a shrub here read Wyatt
let's do this I might put some shrubs by
my lover's peak area oh I can only put
one there alright cool
put one over here too
and Luca flowers so a flowers I went
crazy with the flowers on my Island and
now and now look at me and I'll do what
I have to deal with well it's fine it's
great I love it flowers are one of my
most favorite things what game has Ben
and Johnny thinking of streaming
tomorrow for community Friday good
question I'm not sure actually I do know
that holy moley
it's been a super busy week which I
actually love because I like seeing busy
especially with everything going on it
keeps the mind from wandering too sad
places so I don't know what they're
planning on streaming but there will
definitely be a stream hello here'sh
harish I'm sorry I don't know how to
pronounce that
but hello and welcome thank you for
joining us
I love these events - I'm so happy that
they've got all this action that the
goal is to move this it down a bit so I
can widen up the path and then have
space for the shrubs trucks are hedges
see guys what do you think Bob
[Music]
I'm really excited for red to come to my
Island I hope he's there tomorrow a few
people I know said that they had talked
to blathers last night and then when
they woke up this morning read books
here so I'm like man I should have
signed in like at midnight and talked to
him about it
that would have been awesome oops now
you've been using it as a bellman smash
oh my gosh that's perfect
did this game inspire you to use her cuz
it would inspire me to use her for real
I hear a balloon coming my way I think
there it is come here give me something
good give me some branch or a recipe I
don't own yet that would be really nice
I be patient line up the shot I was like
please don't fall in the water I've lost
too many packages that way click I mean
play is great but I want I want like
furniture or something what was I doing
oh yeah
[Music]
who here has been terraforming their
Island so far her boobless is not that
good I mean Isabel's not the type of
character I look at and I'm like yeah
she's probably an Opie Opie character
although that would be cool if they
partner up with zoom Slayer hey she
could do anything oh my gosh I just saw
a music video that's someone animated of
a song someone wrote about Isabel Indu
and being friends so cute and hilarious
alright so I think I know I didn't do
I'm gonna put some shrubs in each of
these little corners I left out oh my
gosh of course the last square and I had
to mist it
oh no am i dropping frames you guys cuz
I'm dropping Spring Break up a few
hopefully everything's good stuff
for some reason I really love how the
curved edges look so I kind of curved
all the edges on my paths when I can't
sometimes you can't always do it all
right
this wide enough
I think it's wide enough or else I'll
have to go one more square over should
not be a bit yeah
no cream proms okay kit my software is
just scaring me for no reason
[Music]
be nice if it won't fit that but I think
that's too small
Lexi ah so too low so I guess I could go
one more up but then I'm not gonna be
able to fit a shrub in the corner like I
wanted to or will i I actually might be
able to her oh no I will the squares can
be deceiving sometimes oh I thought you
put in the long one
[Music]
ah that's awesome Spidey hey thanks man
hi Mac I've actually been super happy
cuz I just passed my like one year here
at GameSpot it's been so amazing and
yeah and now I feel like you know people
are sharing it remember who I am so it's
really cool
alright oh man am I gonna have to make
this even smaller oh no I wanted to do
that instead
[Music]
well I might have to take these up
anyways so it might not be such a bad
idea you don't know what to do I mean
you don't need online you just have to
build up the island get it all nice and
fancy you know get some villagers
decorate their houses you know turn your
abandoned island into a beautiful place
where a cake a slider would want to come
perform and then once KK comes to
perform you can do all this terraforming
stuff twenties when it really gets fun
[Music]
let me jump thank you No
[Music]
okay I think that's enough gonna be
really tiny a little river right there
poor etosha she was like can you cut it
out you stop ruining my fishing area all
right yeah now I can fit some shrub it's
to me no it's perfect
that's the best thing about this game
you can make your Island however you
want it to be I love it
all right planning some shrubs I still
feel like this part is too close to the
path I put a shrub here it might be
[Music]
a little crowded
[Music]
[Applause]
this is of all a part of the design
process okay I've got an idea I've got a
master plan see oh that's awesome though
I kind of want somebody to come live on
my island to you that's like not a
village right I wish you could have your
let your friends like have a vacation
home on your Island or something
[Music]
okay so I'm gonna move dinoboy over a
bit leave a little space
[Music]
I think that's that's better
I almost feel like that's exactly where
I had it before but I don't think
pockets
I feel like this game is more
therapeutic to me than anything else
Samar you can go be a little creative
have your own little place to like you
know it's like this is my home away from
home pretty much I wanna see something I
want it to be symmetrical that's the
other thank you that's where I'm like
ruined so many times because I want
things to be symmetrical so badly that I
just ended up causing more work for
myself than anything else but I can't
help it like it needs to be even that's
why certain items items that are 1.5 in
dimension are the most cruel thing to me
in this game
the cruelest all right I think I can
yeah some extra space this is starting
to look like a turd emoji actually
[Music]
maybe I shouldn't round out this area
over here now you know what once I have
some bushes up it will no longer look
like a turn I can't put some the bench
back down and everything will be fine
alright so I can definitely move this
over it's still always sold out man yeah
you might as well just skip it that's
the other thing too about physical
copies we were kind of talking about
physical versus digital earlier but at
least digital never sold out that would
be crazy I heard that some fossils are
interactable but I don't know which ones
those are you right oh my goodness see
it's off but I need to again
I move it too much no this is why I have
340 plus hours in the scheme it's me
picking up and putting things back down
cuz they're not symmetrical but that's
why all right beautiful perfect looks
fantastic I love it
I'm gonna put my lanterns back down
right here yeah and then one here okay
yeah see it's coming together once you
start putting things down like what does
like better closer or further um yeah
I'll just still tip the bench in the
middle even though I feel like I should
have something else there now
you make my life easier and not sit
there and rotate it a million places I
can almost put two benches here now oh I
can
hmm I might have to make another bench
I'll put it there for now
all right let's plant some shrubs
I could plant the shrubs here
yeah and that will help me avoid poop
emoji Island right now day wait hold up
Timothy and the chat has some crazy Bell
prices I have never seen prices that
high so if you guys already sold my
turnips this week so I'm missing out but
it's all good if you guys want to take
advantage of that I would highly
recommend especially we got turnips
waiting
[Music]
[Music]
it not gonna let me round that out oh no
it went to pick it all up again to round
it out I mean I would only have to pick
up these last two yes I have to do it I
have to I have to do it does this game
have pandas um if there's a panda
villagers I believe because I know I saw
a panda like yeah yeah like I want to
say maybe it was a bear with like a
panda color but then that's basically a
panda so I'm 99% sure there's a panda
villager
all right
[Music]
oops yeah there's a bunch of panda teddy
bears for sure I have a couple in my
nightclub that I built my seaside
nightclub and
[Music]
I thought I was gonna like it better
with that square filled in but I didn't
and here we are he's turned up circular
yeah yeah it definitely take advantage
of that like the highest price I've ever
seen was like five five hundred or
something like that five something so
yeah
[Music]
alright I'm gonna put some shrubs now
let's do actually let's go get more of
those orange ones so I really like the
orange color
wait what color did I use here I used to
read okay so let's go get more red I'm
gonna need at least three more red
anyways so what up leaf I hear a balloon
here where is it
[Music]
there it is there it is
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah
[Music]
um yes Brandon but can't talk about it
yet oh I got some money
alright turn that away this
but yeah it's gonna be super fun though
so I hope I hope you guys tune in for
that let's plant the shrubs wait what's
my next oh my gosh she's pressing all
the wrong buttons yes oh I don't have
any I gotta do some other things I
thought I would have some more
I wonder if every time I do a nature day
thing he's gonna have some sort of
nature day recipe for me thomna
let's try that after this I cannot wait
until these grow they're gonna be so
cute that's like I keep at 3 on 3 or I
still want to try to keep this area nice
and clear and walkable so I'll do three
on each side
[Music]
yeah we'll just leave it like that for
now
hi guys I want to see how they look like
when they're when they're grown and
they've fully grown what's up Josie
welcome welcome how's it going we're
just checking out some nature day things
and I just planted some shrubs I still
have some more too but yeah that looks
good for now I will leave it be I still
have a ton of flowers so I'm just gonna
drop them off real quick all right now
where else can we put some shrubs mind
my rocks today yet maybe I could put
some by the campsite
[Music]
fossil over here
oh that's awesome eggsy well I'm wishing
her a happy birthday and she's
definitely gonna love it this game is
great I have a lot of fun even if it's
just me planting shrubs for an hour down
for the shrubs right here
the whites up here it's your first ever
live stream I am honored that it's with
us soon oh snap welcome welcome
that's super cool all right
two shrubs down I'm gonna leave those
flowers where they are I think they're
yeah it's not a peach I see back
this AC is so loud at our dessert
okay gotta have an outdoor AC next to
the campsite at home hmm okay tip some
bushes next to our sign here some shrub
I don't know how close these can be next
like to something sometimes you know how
trees can be they'll like their growth
will be stunted if it's too close to
something
I'll just leave it at those two yeah
yeah he not get too crazy I didn't want
to put some bushes around my basketball
career
and I put the fishes in these burners so
that would be nice
oh snap
hopefully those bro
that would be really nice
[Music]
where else can I put some shrubs oh yeah
I'm gonna put them here I have so many
flowers everywhere I've been moving
flowers like crazy girls gonna put some
flowers down I don't want to sell them
but I guess I do have a lot I'm kind of
a surplus right now any tips for
building your island and making it look
nice um some tips from me I guess is or
how I did it is I just went like one
little section at a time worked on that
one little section until I was
completely happy with it and then I
moved on and then eventually you know
yet you get a nice little island you
know I wonder if this well probably not
but you know how the flower is sometimes
breed different special flowers oops I
dropped that I didn't mean to drop that
I wanted to blend it
[Music]
oh nice I have a wrestling ring I gave
it some my jock villager I put it on his
Beach I'm like starting to run out of
space so there's just a bunch of random
stuff everywhere flowers somewhere I'm
literally running out of places to put
flowers here yeah I need to start
considering selling some of these I
guess I mean technically you can throw
them away by don't throw place they're
pretty
bumbum bumbum Oh and I still have
hardwood trees in my pocket I forgot I
moved them okay I'll come back to those
later now there's like so much more to
do so much organization left to do sorry
ander I'm not sure what language you're
speaking there but thanks for joining us
which one did I just put down a red or
away why I'm in pink well the leaves are
a little different so I'll be able to
tell ya oh snap thank you Spidey we've
definitely been working super hard
trying to get everything nice and
awesome for everyone and also just like
keep you guys informed there's a lot of
stuff in this game and a lot of stuff
you could actually miss out on if you
like if you don't know what to look for
so I think it's super cool that we get
to do some tips videos and stuff for you
guys and if you haven't seen them then
just go check out our all right inspire
channel we've got all kinds of good
stuff
yeah I'm gonna fill up this whole row
because I got my girl Annabel below this
clip and she's gonna need some privacy
while she's out lounging in her pool you
kind of seen her yard right there and I
also need more shrubs so let's go hit up
leaf I did red and pink I think so we're
gonna get more red and pink just got to
run all the way over there oh why can't
I fash travel a specific fast travel on
my little island all right what I please
Oh everyone's hanging out in the pool
Thank You Wyatt I would work super hard
on it and it's still a work in progress
there's still a lot to do all right so
we had red and pink get more ideas I'm
nothing to get more than orange when
Susan I think it's so pretty I like that
green and orange combination Oh
Thank You Josie much appreciated hey
we're live every weekday at 2:00 p.m.
Pacific time if you want to come back
for a second stream we will be here
Michael take five I'm starting to think
I shoulda did the red and the orange
together side by side I'm still gonna
get five of these
what kind of stuff do you have on your
island way because I know there's like I
mean I don't know what the exact
qualifications are for a three-star but
there are things that they want you to
have on the island like you know all the
fruits and they want you to put down
fences and they're want they want there
to be you know a certain amount of
villagers and stuff like that so you
know I'm sure the end like they do take
into consideration like how much
furniture you have like on the island
like I have all these like tables and
chairs and stuff all right
which one I heard another balloon it
sounds like I missed it though or I'm
about to missus homeless missed it might
be two yay thank goodness for that
little whooshing noise oh they watch em
yeah they won't you'd have flowers and
like flowers and different colors and
stuff like that so like I got a lot of
the flowers I didn't have from like
mystery islands or just visiting people
okay we had a pink one
[Music]
no I needed a red one lick my pockets
there we go
she really buried it in the wrong wall
you'd rather be up my Ellen then go to
Disney I don't know it was pretty great
this is pretty great
[Music]
and read alright this is gonna look so
cute when it's done when they've a grown
[Music]
put somebody's back down alright what
else
[Music]
honestly I have no idea what you guys
are saying and I can't Google Translate
right now those guys are being nice one
can only hope in this digital world I
think I might put some shrubs right
there it's you it's fine yeah for real
like this scam I feel like it's just
totally taking over which is great I'm
not mad about it at all
alright where else can we put some
shrubs
[Music]
ooh
Dobies home let's see if he's crafting
anything
[Music]
doesn't sound like Hughes he's doing
some yoga he's so adorable
I gave him so much furniture and he's
still using these boxes as tables
well I won't use my furniture I don't
think he likes that I gave him he did
put some of the stuff I gave him like I
gave him this this drawer here and that
chair and this stool that he clearly
[Music]
he's it's in there maybe I should give
him more tables I guess maybe he just
didn't like the ones that I gave to him
man I'm really excited for red to come
to my island girl yeah he has the UH he
has the library wallpaper which takes
like ten books to craft as a recipe I
crapped it one for my friend as a gift
but I didn't realize who took so many
books it took me forever so you get that
so it's all good all right what is there
to do next you planted some shrubs what
else I still have more shrubs plant - oh
let's do some of these let's try to get
another natured a nook thing so that I
can see if I get more in nature day
recipes from Tom Nick let's see my
villagers are chilling why you got your
back turn to pan Shetty like that funny
one of them was spin some nip miles so
let's go spend some Nick miles
oh cool see you later Brandon yeah I'm
definitely gonna eat some lunch after
this treat myself it had such a busy day
didn't I have a chance to eat anything
now
starvin all right let's redeem some
miles I'm gonna redeem another bucket I
only needed to redeem 500 I think so
yeah have a good one thank you so much
for stopping by as always okay give us a
neat oh wait what what is this redeem
Nick Myles odd did that oh wait
where my pockets people well then they
were I'd say I see I see I see
oh man all right i'ma sell these flowers
I have a surplus of flowers DCCC I did
get all the egg day and all the cherry
blossom recipes actually yes all these
flowers cuz I have extra lot of flowers
so I must leave those out there too
because I like that one a lot
cool 600 only 600 for all those flowers
ding um a Google search told me that our
buddies in chat we're definitely calling
me inappropriate names which is why I
have to get them out of here sorry guys
no heat here we're just trying to have
fun on Animal Crossing not trying to be
berated but it's all good it happens it
happens I'm nothing
there are more like Nature Day recipes
because I really like the hedgerows view
fence
already I think it's really good
so let's go bump bump bump bump bump
okay now my pockets are and more empty
you get only one nature day thing per
day Oh from thomna or get one nature day
objective per day because then that
makes sense yeah it's old spar you show
some respect in this chat not just for
me but for everybody in the shed
everybody hanging out we're just having
a good time we don't need none of that
it's all good Josie things it's cool
guys they're not the first ones they
won't be the last but as long as you
guys are here having a good time and
bring in the positivity when I need it
most
that's all I care about all right I
don't think I'm gonna go to the neck
island immediately man I wish I had
talked to
blathers yesterday night so that I could
have had read today for the stream but
it's all good
where else can I put some shrubs though
that's the question I need more trucks
and more hedges I actually really like
the hedges a lot I love I thought I
redid my closet here because it's super
cute it used to just be all flowers but
I moved the fountain here those were
good times so it was a good fence
all right I'm wondering if I should I
still kind of like this though oh yeah I
wanted to surround I'm gonna surround oh
my gosh I have to pluck up so many
flowers to do that
but I kind of wanted to surround that
with a hedge of some sort
decisions decisions this is my museum by
the way I've made it a very pretty
oh yeah I didn't show you guys my
nightclub I don't think but for the
person was asking about the pandas yeah
they're definitely pandas wait is my my
DJ booth is off this is unacceptable
unacceptable always KK house always I
can't wait to see what these shrubs look
like when they're built Oh
hopefully ranae is building something
[Music]
nope
is she sick no oh okay
good thing I stopped by cuz I gotta get
her some medicine I know I love them the
nightclub my friend has a really cool
nightclub on her Island which has
inspired me to be one of my own but like
crazy looks way better is mine alright
let me get some medicine for Rene and
then we're all gonna call it here
shortly but thank you guys for tuning in
don't forget every single weekday at
2:00 p.m. Pacific time you guys can come
and watch and now on Tuesdays and
Thursdays sorry Katie missed streaming
as well so even more live streams and
more chances you guys come hang out
which is super awesome
Oh whispy said Lionel is moving out if
anyone wants to trave let them know and
also hey what's up with speed how's it
going uh medicine yes we got it
all right let's go give Rene this
medicine and then we will call it a day
I know whenever I see any of my
villagers sick or like they have fleas
or something I like no I must help them
immediately okay
don't worry Rene we got you we got you
okay don't worry I got you girl
I've got you girl medicine delivery all
right boom hey all right she is all
better what is the community game for
tomorrow I'm not sure yet but definitely
tune in we will be live and we will be
hanging with you guys Ben and Gianluca
are always holding that down so yeah
make sure you come on back I hope you
guys had a great time I had fun I hope
you're looking forward to everything
that the nature Day event is bringing
I'm super stoked for the museum I'm
hoping that I find all the art pieces I
mean I just found all the fossils so I'm
just hoping I can get all the art and
finish getting all the fish and
everything else I want a hundred percent
that Museum as much as I can all right
you guys thank you so much have a good
one and make sure you tune in next time
you